who took a lot of globe was that you
sorry listen david
it's my first time in a podcast studio
okay but you just took a
audible slurp and then i think it was
the straw
the point is you held it right up to the
microphone i take discreet sips
and i do it away from the microphone you
have this um
i think it's the largest water bottle
i've ever seen it looks like you stole a
prop from land of the giants
it's from home goods 60s reference tv
show anywho
you took a giant slurp and then i could
feel the water being pushed down your
esophagus
all the way into your belly so just be a
little mindful of that okay sure
how dare you so sorry if you're just
joining us uh we're
mid conversation with david hopping
who's gonna get transitioned into sona's
role as assistant
and that's what this segment is it's the
second part of a major cliffhanger from
last episode major
major people have been beating down our
doors to find out what happens
wow that was me just trying to get in to
kill you
um for calling this a cliffhanger the
crux of the matter here is that
one sona tallinn me obsession i used
your middle name
but not her last name you did something
weird with my last name also tallinn is
my first name
i know but you were you go by sony
yes but your real name is tony see this
i just took us into a cul-de-sac we
didn't have to go into
exactly let me try that again what we're
going to do today
is uh as you all know i think you're
aware that sona is
carrying twins at this very moment yeah
to
unborn uh children in her belly who have
to listen to this
the podcast some parents play mozart to
them yes
i was going to say i was going to say
kids hear mozart they hear chopin
they hear beethoven your two children
have
for months during the uh you know most
important stages of their
cerebral development listen to us
bicker yeah and self-obsess and waste
time
they're gonna know your voice more than
they're gonna know text
and that makes me really sad that's
right
they'll never listen to your husband
tack and so you'll have to call me and
put and hold the phone out to them and
i'll say go to your cribs
and they'll both immediately like little
soldiers march off to their cribs oh my
god but
um no we're really excited for you we're
really happy thank you
and uh it's this event is going to
happen very soon
so obviously uh we need to find someone
to temporarily replace you
and the man for the job is david hopping
who has been uh
working in our office for five years
you've been working as jeff
ross's assistant he's our executive
producer
a man of few words very very few words
what's up what's going on
hey how are you doing let's go i gotta
go
and he is uh what is he he's not the
opposite of
ice no he's an oven mitt oh oh
i am a flame that needs to be controlled
and he just he just comes down like a
big oven mitten
and extinguishes that flame okay doesn't
oven mitt extinguish the flame
i mean no he's a fire blanket like that
kind of thing yeah i was thinking
something that cuts off the
oxygen okay fire all right okay
well this is the cliffhanger resolution
people have been
screaming this is a waste of
everybody's time david let's try to get
to the heart of the matter
david do you know what your duties are
as far as being my assistant
not really because i'm very different
you're working now for jeff ross the
executive producer of the show
yeah okay and he's a guy who probably
wants to have a dinner reservation
probably wants you to tell him what's in
his appointment book what he has to do
sona and i don't have that kind of
relationship no okay
90 of what conan is going to tell you
and talk to you about is complete and
utter
nonsense wouldn't you say i call it
gibberish lots of so many bits then you
have to like weed through
a huge dense amount of bits to get to
something that has any sort of sort of
substance i call
sona often as other people um i'm
constantly saying i was in i was using
the restroom and i walked out and i had
forgotten to pull up my pants
and i walked into a restaurant and i
started braiding a waiter with no pants
on and tmz was there and they have all
the footage
and i panicked at that point and said
some stuff that was against america
and like i keep making the story worse
and worse and worse just so i'll spend
15 minutes on that and then i'll say oh
and by the way the medication that keeps
me alive i'm completely out of that
yeah i don't lead with the most
important thing so you have to be
patient and listen to my bits okay i can
do that
so many bits what do you do you just sit
i just sit there
i literally just sit there and just
listen to it okay that's all you can do
but i think david's asking a much more
intriguing question is
what is it you do oh i mean i don't mean
just with well i'm well i'm telling you
a story because that's occasional
but when i'm around putting a show
together uh crafting a comedic
sensibility that will guide a generation
to higher heights
what are you doing that's a good
question uh
and um you know i there's there's things
that i should be doing and then there's
things that i do
so i think those are two completely
different ideas that you have that was
very good you just
if you were in front of the senate being
grilled they would not be able to pin
you down
yeah that was amazing wasn't that
amazing should be doing
and then there are things that i do so
most of my day and david and i worked
have worked very closely for a long time
yeah most of our days spent talking
about what we're gonna get for lunch
then ordering lunch then sending someone
out for lunch then
eating lunch so that already sucks up
like half of our day
yeah you know if you have shows to catch
up on or movies you want to watch
then that's important so i started out
as conan your production assistant right
and sona one day told me if i'm ever
just waiting at my desk for her to tell
me to do something it's fine if i watch
tv
yeah don't fire me for saying this but i
sat at my desk and binged
14 seasons of grey's anatomy
is grey's anatomy still on yeah they
just got renewed it's amazing that show
is still on
but it's it's like gunsmoke you know
it's like a show from the 50s that's
still going
it's a good thing that it's still on
because you're going to have a job where
you need to watch it
yeah yeah and now i'm basically a doctor
so
so you watched 14 seasons of grey's
anatomy that's incredible
and on my dime i was paying you well i
was waiting for
sona to tell me like if you needed lunch
or something right
i'm watching chicago hope right now
chicago
i don't know just was it still i'm never
that was on was that the big competitor
to grey's anatomy
i don't know and then it went away after
like a year or is it or
i don't know these shows that are on
conventional television you know
channels
two four seven when's the last time i
stumbled onto one of those
yeah and i'm always on some streaming
platform
watching uh schteizel um it's a good
show actually
i like it i like my weird european shows
you know with subtitles i do too and
then after i watch them i feel like i
know the language i was watching that's
not how language works
i was watching uh some show uh i forget
what it was but it was on netflix
and it was this foreign obscure show
with subtitles and it was like dutch or
something and then after a while i
realized this
is just grey's anatomy yeah they're just
doing
they're just coming in through the side
door you know it was
very similar people and uh and it was
really no different they were just but i
was giving it all this cred
yeah because it had subtitles it's much
better i watched call my agent which is
in french
and then i watched summertime which is
an in italian and then i also had
watched
money heist which is in spanish and i
really feel like after i'm done with all
those shows that i can speak
all those languages fluently not only
studied
abroad exactly i watched the bureau
and money heist and i felt like yeah i'm
just a classics enthusiast i got all the
romantic languages down
you know what happens i watch those
shows i i watch shows like that uh and i
like to watch on a treadmill
and um i'm running it full tilt and i'm
reading
that tiny you know uh subtitles
going by and my eyes are like on fire
by the time the show is over because my
head's bouncing up and down because
that's how i run i
lope more than i run i lope like a great
wildebeest i had to mention
full tilt too didn't you you just had to
like make sure everybody knew like
it's the toughest one did i flex
i mean for me full tilt might not be for
you know an olympic athlete full tilt oh
yeah compared yourself to an olympic
athlete oh i just said a f
an olympic athlete would be full out
running i my fast walk
feels to me like full you know you're
one
yes any who we're learning a lot about
you david
doing nothing about david david quickly
just tell us
do you think this is going to be an easy
job i think so
i don't i'm not a demanding guy am i no
i think i'm emotionally demanding but i
don't
ask for a lot of stuff i've also after
five years never seen you
get mad i don't well not really mad i
get fake mad
all the time that's true i get fake mad
constantly yeah you know but um
you're not like uh you're not a yeller
you don't throw things
i'm going to though now why why would
you do that it's going to be a whole new
conan when you come back
yeah why i don't know i feel like david
will just understand
and david you quickly tell us your
obsessions i know that you're
obsessed with disneyland i love
disneyland i haven't been back since
they reopened but
david well there was a story halfway
through the pandemic about someone who
broke into disneyland and went to that
island
like swam to the island and was living
there and the workers at disneyland
found him and i sent it to you and said
david was this you
that's how much david hopping loves
disneyland and
britney spears i do i'm curious
had you thought of it are you the type
of person who would have broken into
disneyland and lived on that island for
a bit
no because i wouldn't wanted to risk
getting banned for life
that's the only thing that would have
stopped you yeah
okay that's true you would have been
banned for life
yeah oh he'd have come back with like a
big fake mustache just get tons of
plastic surgery yeah i'm schmidt
yeah i'm schmidt i'm schmidt and i don't
work for schmon and o'brien
schmopping i'm schmabish mopping and
i've never heard of shimon and o'brien
uh that makes no sense in any in any way
all right well i think you're gonna work
out fine david
and uh i'm really rooting for you and uh
i think you're going to be a wonderful
permanent replacement for sonoma
permanent wow keep saying permanent
whatever it's just it's a freudian slip
it's when you accidentally say your
deepest desire
okay not permanent maybe who knows i'll
be fine
you'll be back you just love working
with me and i know it i mean i don't
know
love is the right word but it's i
tolerate it because you don't hate it
i don't hate it so that's good it's nice
you know
let me go to we go to lunch or something
i find somewhere really expensive
oh that's a good idea yeah yeah you got
to look for four dollar signs
because he's rich yeah because wow rich
is a relative term
a celebrity's gone i'm actually quite
impoverished i don't think
i'm congressman i started gofundme for
what
we gotta get conan up to clooney levels
he's got that tequila
the sad part is people would do it yeah
i want my own uh we've got to help conan
out
you know he's not quite he's not at
clooney level he got that tequila
i tried to come out with my own knockoff
of snapple
i was gonna say do you think you have
the right brand for tequila
no i don't know i think a pomade i keep
thinking a pomade
i think a pomade is right i don't think
or like a little wine cooler or
something
that might be good yeah sort of a nice
rose fizzy
uh yeah one of those wines that sort of
tastes like an apple juice
and it's actually it's such a tame wine
that it's been approved for children by
the fda
all right well let's move on but uh
david i'm very good to have you aboard
thank you